Philippe Martinez et oui qui a laissé sa
place à Sophie Binet la new patronne de
la CGT c'est terminé ce duo berger
Martinez nous ne verrons plus les les
Catherines et Liliane du syndicalisme
mais c'est un peu les Daft Punk du
bordel social Daft Punk c'est surtout le
plus grand mystère de la planète people
depuis leur début en 1993 jamais ils
l'ont montré leur visage au public mais
mercredi dans la matinale de France
Inter événement Salamé votre invité ce
matin est un musicien mythique et la
moustache qui est faux
tu reviendrais bientôt j'ai essayé de
pas écouter mais c'était pas simple ça
s'appelle Nathalie bien commencer ce
tournoi en se disant tu sais quoi je
c'est un même pour moi les règles sont
un mystère et je vais donner la réponse
ouais c'est aussi compliqué pour moi du
coup je suis désolé je j'y vais
franchement alors à quoi ça ressemble un
Daft Punk en vrai bonjour Thomas
bangelter
en gros qui s'habiller vite fait et qui
est surtout hyper content d'être là
alors pour ceux qui confondent Lolo
berger et philo Martinez le lot
aubergiste celui qui n'a pas un hamster
mort sous le nez
[Rires]
et Martinez c'est facile c'est celui qui
a un peu un look d'un acteur porno des
années 70
[Applaudissements]
des chercheurs ont demandé à des jeunes
hommes de mesurer eux-mêmes leur poids
leur taille leur force et la taille de
leur pénis vous savez déjà comment ça va
se terminer les hommes ont légèrement
surévalué leur taille leur force
physique mais surtout ils ont beaucoup
surévaluer leur pénis
[Applaudissements]
selon les statistiques concernant la
population locale la moyenne aurait dû
être de 14,9 cm en érection et dans
l'étude c'était 18 cm
soit une augmentation de plus de 20%
c'est vrai que quitte à mentir autant le
faire dans les grandes largeurs ou le
médecin placent-ils les embouts de son
stéthoscope pour reculer
dans les oreilles non c'est mieux que ce
soit dans les oreilles
vous voyez ce que je veux dire
qu'à l'époque en plus on me demandait de
doubler tout et tout le monde il fallait
suivre les scénario mais autant vous
dire que dans les films porno le
scénario c'est pas l'intrigue c'est pas
ce dont ils se soucis plus tu vois donc
c'est très simple ça faisait bonjour
bonjour
[Musique]
je commence
et après
mais là où ça devient encore plus
intéressant c'est que pour faire cette
étude les hommes qui ont participé
étaient rémunérés et les chercheurs ont
trouvé que moins c'était payé plus
augmentés la taille de leur pénis
j'ai adoré ta phrase quand on t'a
demandé est-ce qu'il y avait un petit
peu de jalousie avec les autres prof de
la Star Ac et tu as répondu en vrai il y
avait pas de jalousie parce que il y
avait pas de débats j'étais là ils
étaient là
je l'ai pas dit comme ça mais c'était
extraordinairement jeune Pablo Picasso
est-ce que vous pensez quelquefois vous
savez
peut-être que c'est une jeune est-ce que
vous pensez quelquefois la mort non
avant
[Musique]
on vieillit pas de la même façon tu vois
et moi je fais tout à la maison je
réfléchis pour deux je pense pour deux
je suis chargée mentalement et du coup
que plus que lui je pense vraiment que
Brigitte Macron n'est pas n'est pas plus
âgé que le président
elle est juste chargée
mais vous avez tellement raison je suis
marié depuis 19 ans je sais plus quoi
raconter
[Rires]
c'est un petit attaquant
il se passe plus rien depuis longtemps
les voisins un homme célibataire et ses
parents se plaignent essentiellement des
nuisances sonores causées par les bovins
[Musique]
aussi
est-ce que je peux te poser une question
il y avait des salaires qui étaient
sortis dans la presse tout ça c'est
vulgaire mais c'était quoi
le tien mais je trouve ça un peu enfin
un peu type de parler des salaires enfin
vraiment le chips si tu veux
je trouve que tu les vaux largement je
possède des thunes je suis à l'aise
financièrement je ne me plains pas les
affaires marchent en ce moment Laura
partage une astuce pour recevoir à
moindre frais de brocolis comme cette
valise remplie l'étudiante espagnole
actuellement en Italie passe par le site
de vente entre particuliers vintage elle
crée une fausse annonce avec un compte
ici une poubelle à 1 euro et avec un
autre compte elle l'achète et bénéficie
alors des tarifs préférentiels de la
plateforme sur les frais d'expédition
elle n'a plus qu'à envoyer par email
l'étiquette à ses parents qui lui envoie
la fameuse valise du coup j'achète des
trucs et les gens voient que j'ai des
trucs il suffit il a des trucs
et du coup je suis content selon elle
l'économie serait importante 6 euros
contre 50 par la voie postale classique
une technique totalement interdite par
le règlement de vinted nous nous
l'aimons bien dans le groupe Canal
Michel Jonah il locataire connu dans un
portage j'étais drôle d'ailleurs qui a
été diffusé alors vous voyez il était à
la pompe je sais pas si vous avez USA il
était à la pompe à essence dans un
reportage diffusé sur TF1 et puis la
journaliste a dit ce monsieur a du mal à
trouver le bon sens mais c'était Michel
Jonas mais vous avez pas vu ça moi
j'aurais pas c'est
alors c'est la séquence qui a la une de
tous les journaux de toutes les réseaux
sociaux ou évangile amour est resté
et voir si l'un de nos deux bouches
couché sur les fourmis
[Musique]
merci Michel Jeunesse